This has an
immediate effect on everything, right?
You owe our lives everything.
Just in the US Bureau of Labor Statistics
just announcing
how many jobs were added
to the economy in February.
Christine Romans here with the numbers.
So a lot of hiring.
This is good or bad.
If you are looking for a job, it's good.
If you have a job and you're job hopping,
it's good.
It is a strong job market.
311,000 jobs added.
And we know it was a blockbuster report
in January
that was revised down
a little bit to 504,000.
That's still a very, very big number.
This shows you that businesses are hiring
despite those headlines
you've seen of tech companies
that have been laying people off.
They hired a lot during the pandemic.
Despite those headlines,
this is a very, very strong job market.
3.6% is the unemployment
rate went up a little bit.
That's because
about 400,000 people
came off the sidelines
and started looking for work.
So that's an unemployment rate
rising for a good reason.
People are hearing from friends
they know that there are plentiful jobs
and so they're out looking for work now.
And then the sectors, guys, the leisure,
hospitality, hiring
a lot of people retail, government jobs.
So we broke out for a lot of
just a lot of jobs across the board.
So it's good for employees,
bad for employers, bad for the Fed. Yeah.
So a good economy
could eventually be bad news
for Americans
because it means the Fed
has to continue to raise interest rates.
You've got wages up 4.6%.
That's great.
I mean, people's
paychecks are unequivocally bigger.
But it's
feeding into the inflation story.
And so the Fed thinks that inflation
staying too high is more dangerous
than maybe
trying to cool off the job market
a little bit.
So I know it's upside down.
Well, it's weird
because everybody I talked to
and they said
just yesterday
I was having breakfast
with a bunch of folks and they said,
Don, we're so confused.
When you guys talk about the economy,
you get the new jobs
numbers in the stock market.
Everything's going gangbusters.
But again, it's bad.
What do I don't know what to say to them.
You know, it's it's interesting
because we kind of broke all the
the models after COVID.
And so we're trying
we have a very confusing picture
of the economy.
The underlying strength of the economy
over the past
six weeks has been undeniable.
The consumer
retail sales,
the job market and inflation
is still too high.
All of this is a function
of us, of a strong recovery
in the economy.
And while that is good news,
it feels like good news.
If it feeds into inflation
and inflation
gets entrenched,
then that slows growth
and then that can cause a recession.
And the question
everyone is paying
close attention to this,
not just us, it's the White House,
our senior White House correspondent
and daily is on the line.
M.J., obviously,
they are always looking closely to this.
You reported
they were looking for this Goldilocks
number, got a lot higher than Goldilocks.
It's way more than expected.
What's the reaction
you're hearing so far?
Yeah, Caitlin,
the number that White House officials
had really been
hoping to see
was something in the mid 200.
So you're right
that this is a little bit
bigger than that.
But I can say I suspect
that they're going to be pretty
pleased with this.
You know, that Goldilocks
number that we talk about
they wanted something
that wasn't too big like like what
we saw in the month of January
when the economy
added more than 500,000 jobs.
That was frankly shocking
to a lot of economists.
But they obviously also
always want to see
strength and robustness
in the jobs market.
And so much of this has to do
with being on federal reserve watch.
They knew
and very much took note
inside the building
behind me
when Jerome
Powell said
in recent days and suggested
that if there are more
indicators of the jobs
market is just too hot,
that the labor market is too hot,
that, yeah,
the central bank
could bring back
more aggressive interest rate hikes.
That's not something that the White House
wants to see.
But at the same time,
this is almost sort of been
a good problem
for the White House to have.
You know, they know that the labor market
being too strong and being too hot
can lead to more aggressive
interest rate hikes.
But at the same time,
they're always going to say, look,
more jobs being added, more paychecks
going out to Americans.
That is essentially a good thing.
And, you know,
I don't have to tell you
the issue of the economy,
the issue of inflation.
Those are some of the most important
political issues for this White House.
And for Democrats heading into 20, 24.
So they're always going to sort of root
for strength in the jobs market.
And they do basically feel like
they have a good story
to tell on the economy.
But again,
inflation is the one
sort of intractable problem
that this president has faced.
And they very much
want to see that trend
to continue in a downward manner.
Yeah, we'll see what President Biden says
when he speaks out.
MJ, Christine,
thank you
both so much
for breaking down those massive,
very hot jobs numbers today.
CNN Economics
and political commentator Catherine
Rampell joining us this morning.
So here's what I think.
And I don't think I'm
the only one, right?
I think a number of viewers and Americans
in general struggle with as well.
So we have this strong jobs
report, right?
So the jobs market is still hot.
Looking at some of those sectors,
you had pretty significant gains
in leisure and hospitality and in retail.
So people are needed in those sectors,
which means people are spending money.
And we know the US
economy depends on consumer spending.
Inflation is still too high, though.
So what are we supposed
to make of all of this
sort of a similar formula
that we've been seeing?
How do I put it all in perspective this
morning, Catherine?
It is legitimately confusing.
This is the 11th consecutive month
when forecasters have expected much lower
job growth than we got And it's weird.
I mean, we've had eight rate
hikes, eight interest rate hikes.
A lot of people were expecting,
if not a slowdown,
maybe even a recession.
But this recession is like
Waiting for Godot.
You know,
it's like people keep thinking
it's around the corner
and then it never arrives,
which is generally good news, right?
I mean, nobody's
really rooting for a recession.
But it is puzzling
how the economy has been able to maintain
its strength,
how the job market has been able
to maintain its strength.
Given these predictions,
and given the great stress
on the economy today.
So you're not alone.
It's it's hard to make sense of.
First of all, very good
literary reference there.
Second of all,
the Fed is trying this balance, right?
They listen,
we should be celebrating
a strong job market.
That means Americans
can find jobs and get paid.
By the way, the pay is going up as well.
But trouble
is, prices are still staying high.
The Fed and I understand
you and me and folks watching
want to get those prices down.
Why aren't the interest rate
hikes working so far?
It's pretty aggressive ramp up.
And how far do you see them
needing to go before
they begin to have an effect?
Again, it's a little bit unclear.
Is this about
there's just a longer lag
between the time when the Fed raises
interest rates
and it's really felt in the economy
or maybe we don't know
what the alternative universe
would have been.
Maybe
the economy would have been
even stronger, booming even more.
Absent these rate hikes,
I also wonder to
what extent fiscal policy
is still playing a role in in
helping the economy expand,
especially at the state level.
Most states
have cut taxes in the past year.
Almost every state has cut taxes
in the past two years.
So that's still giving people money
to spend.
That might be part of the explanation
here.
Know,
we also don't know
if if our headline numbers
are capturing all of the stress
that's out there.
There might be something
we're missing in part because of
this weird economy.
You tweeted
yesterday, I'm
paraphrasing here,
but if I remember,
it seems the effect of
no matter what the jobs report shows,
the Fed is going to be mad.
How does the Fed deal with this latest
bit of data
Well, what I said was
people will be mad at the Fed.
Very sorry about that. Very challenging.
That's okay. They're not that different.
But I think the Fed is in
a really challenging position
because we have these
contradictory signals,
strong jobs market,
some stress in the financial sector.
Inflation too high, maybe send signals
that some of those pressures
might be coming down,
but then they reverse themselves.
So who knows?
I think the Fed is looking at this
report and saying, hmm,
the job market
still looks stronger than we anticipated.
There are
some signs that monetary policy is doing
we want it to do.
But it's not sufficient.
Next week,
we will get new inflation data.
I think that there's going to be
a lot of attention paid to those data,
and that will affect what the Fed does.
But I think we should anticipate
rate hikes continuing for a while.
You said something interesting there.
You said that part of the inflationary
push here are tax cuts at the state level
because all that
in the political environment,
all the criticism
has been leveled at COVID
relief money
going back a couple of years now.
But but are you saying that there's
there's inflationary tax
policy at the state level?
Yes.
I mean, I don't know how
big the magnitude is,
but states have had these
huge budget surpluses
in the last few years.
That's partly
because the economy has been quite strong
and they have strong tax revenues.
It's also partly
because they got a lot of money
from Congress.
So they have a lot of money to play with.
And that money was supposed to be used,
of course,
for making investments
in schools and various other things.
And to some extent, it's
been used to just hand it back
over to taxpayers
in the form of property rate
cuts, income tax cuts, etc..
And so we don't have a great sense
because there isn't like
a central database,
a central repository
that tells us how that money
is flowing through to taxpayers.
But I think it's quite possible
that that's part of the story here.
People have more money to play with.
Catherine Rampell
always good to talk to you.
Appreciate it. Thanks.